this is a swan
a little smiley face
swan or willy
[Music]
hello gq my name is jonatha bailey and
these
are my 10 essential items
you ready for number one
the books my two essential books at the
moment one is matt hague's the comfort
book this book is like a bible of really
lovely little tidbits to help you
through
what could be a stressful time pandemic
very helpful
here's one for instance
page 147 clarity you are here and that
is enough this is something that offers
a very uh lovely amount of relief and
it's like a cuddle and then the second
one is a play text of [ __ ]
next march we'll be opening this play
with taran edgerton it's going to be
directed by marian elliott who is
brilliant and this play [ __ ] is
small but well formed
i sort of worry a lot about learning the
lines but i feel like if i've got that
on my person then i sort of feel by
osmosis it will just come in so if it's
in my pocket i feel like i'm doing the
work keep my [ __ ] in my pocket
[Music]
measly wherever i go i have a massive
stash of measly it's only sort of
recently that i've remembered my dad
used to take muesli wherever he went as
well
so it's some sort of genetic
predisposition to love the oats and the
pulses are taken almond milk and oat
milk but basically i'm not really fussy
about the milk part or the bowl or the
spoon but the muesli i'm hyper fussy
about and that's the one i particularly
like this one because it's got
desiccated coconut in it which really
lifts the top notes the bottom notes
it can be sort of like a pudding it can
be a start or a main course or it could
be a seven-course taster menu
[Music]
for my next essential item
this is my key pairing polaroid camera
there's oats in the lens
there's measly in my camera on set for
bridgeton they sort of had a rule that i
took quite seriously that you went on
your mobile phones on set to take
pictures so i thought maybe this is the
way to go analog and
you know
beat the bosses i've got one left are
you ready
there's loads of muesli
i think the thing about polaroids is
that you've got them in the flesh and
actually i missed that about photos
these you know you can pop on the wall
and they're really satisfying
as you'll see soon in about
two minutes and 10 seconds
this
is definitely an essential item because
it has my keys attached it was a gift
from lara lauren like the best team a
man can get as a rap gift they bought me
this you have to guess what it is
[Music]
this
this is a swan
swan quickly became the code word for
in the face of panic
gliding through
there is a smiley face
swan or willy
[Music]
i think some people are born with skin
care and some have skin care thrust upon
them and i think i'm the latter and i've
got two products to share with you
hyaluronic acid
it's been described as a glass of water
for the face despite the fact it's got
acid i don't know what it means it
sounds terrifying but yeah it took me
about six months to learn how to
pronounce it and now i've got it i just
keep saying it to everyone hyaluronic
iron
hyaluronic
so i'd say that first followed by
my all-time favorite
emma hardy
emma i don't know where you are but
you're bloody golden it's like a
superfood for the skin it gives you a
little glow and actually every product
that emma hardy does is unrivalled i
think you know golden by nature and
in design
this next one
is actually broken i can see and it's
been broken for a while but it's
actually some bath salts
i think there's a general theme in my
essential items of um
self-care this is heckles stress fix
soaking bath salts and actually was
bought for me by simone ashley aka kate
sharma series two of bridgeton they sort
of smell unbelievable
lavender and
sort of eucalyptus i'd say i love a bath
always have always will if i could have
brought a bathtub that would have been
the essential item
[Music]
this is a worry pebble
i do literally take this everywhere and
you can just sort of rub it when it
calms you down it used to be massive it
used to be a boulder
and it was tiny so i only got a few more
weeks left in the sun i think it was
back at school the teachers were always
like you just need something to focus
your energies
the thing is you know with regency
outfits there's not really much space
for anything apart from the boots
everyone keeps their phones in their
boots in bridgeton don't tell anyone
music
is such a massive part of my life so
these are master dynamic in-ear
headphones actually a birthday present
from ted sarandos
head of netflix
that i'll always leave them out on the
side on charge right by the door and
then they'll be the like last thing i
take off as i go in and the first thing
i
you know what i mean my playlist at the
moment is pretty eclectic
wenger boys
is quite high up there and big wild
steven's on time
a bit actually destiny's child i
recently got asked under pressure by a
friend what album i should play and i
just screamed through the door
dusty's charlotte's second album so yeah
they're always around
[Music]
my next two essential items fanny packs
this is kind of grubby because this is
one that's still very much in use it's
got some dental floss in it and some
shells
oh it's got some euros
and
and a bill
see
and then this it's a funny pack but it's
also my favorite north face jacket
this will be like my festival
festival fanny
with raspberry flavor vitamin c
electrolytes
really crusty oh didn't
prep this
[Music]
and for the ultimate hand
cozy
my mittens
[Music]
which i wear all the time
super cozy
and they have a little flower so you can
you know you can do
documentate yours whilst knowing that
you can just sort of snug them up and
swaddle them freedom within comfort
which is the dream
great
oh the polaroid
oh yeah
can you see it can you get a picture on
that
you thought it was an intimate affair
but there's actually 12 people in the
room
i've been drawn to bailey and you've
been looking at my essential 10 items
also known as a
self-care kit someone just screamed
she needs a warrior stone quick
and a bowl of muesli
[Music]